التدريبات المنتظمة تساوي أكثر
بكثير من ستة عبوات ولكننا نعلم جميعًا كيف أن
التمارين الجيدة لجسمك أكثر صحة للقلب
ورئتين أكثر صحة ، لكنهم لم يفكروا أبدًا في
مدى جودة
التمارين لعقلك ، وتأكد أنك ربما
سمعت شخصًا ما يخبرك
يتم إطلاق الإندورفين عند ممارسة الرياضة ، ولكن ما
الذي يعنيه هذا جيدًا حقًا ، إليك طريقة
للتفكير عندما تبدأ في التمرين ،
يتعرف دماغك على أنها
لحظة توتر حيث يزيد ضغط الدم في قلبك
، يعتقد الدماغ أنك
إما تقاتل عدوًا أو  أنت
تفر من قتال أو رحلة واحدة '
تحمي نفسك وعقلك من
الإجهاد ، تقوم بإطلاق هذا البروتين المعروف باسم
عامل التغذية العصبية المشتق من الدماغ BDNF ،
وهو مادة رائعة جدًا في نفس
الوقت يتم إطلاق الإندورفين مادة كيميائية أخرى
لمكافحة الإجهاد بواسطة
الغدة النخامية  يقلل الإندورفين من
الانزعاج الناتج عن التمرين ، فهو يمنع
الشعور بالألم ، بل إنه مرتبط أيضًا
بمشاعر النشوة التي يمكنك سماع
شيء آخر يبحث عنها  نُشر في
المجلة العلمية Nature ،
لذا فإن الأشخاص الذين يمارسون الرياضة فقط
زادوا من المادة الرمادية في أدمغتهم ،
وهذا هو الدماغ ، لكنني أريد أيضًا أن أسمح
لك بممارسة القليل من التمارين السرية التي
تقدم دفعة جادة لتقدير الذات
يمكن أن تكون بمثابة الإندورفين
أيضًا.  لا يغير الخروج من
مظهرك الجسدي فحسب ، بل يؤثر أيضًا
على الطريقة التي ترى بها نفسك وفقًا
لاستطلاع أجرته مؤسسة غالوب مؤخرًا ، يشعر الأمريكيون الذين
يمارسون الرياضة بشكل أفضل بشأن
مظهرهم ، وسأخبرك بغض النظر
عما يحدث في حياتي أو مدى انشغالي.
هل أشعر دائمًا بتحسن أعتقد
أنني أفضل أداء إذا خصصت وقتًا لممارسة
التمارين ، يوصي مركز السيطرة على الأمراض (CDC) جميع البالغين بالحصول على
ساعتين ونصف على الأقل من تمارين
القلب المعتدلة الشدة أسبوعيًا بالإضافة إلى
أنشطة تقوية العضلات في يومين أو أكثر
في الأسبوع تعمل جميعها
مجموعات العضلات الرئيسية التي تبدو الآن وكأنها الكثير
من الوقت ، لا يمكنك تفريق
نشاطك وقليل من عشر دقائق
مقطوعة وسأخبرك أن الوقت قد تم
قضائه جيدًا
هنا  كيف بدأت في جعلها عادة ،
أرتدي ملابسي الرياضية وأضعها مباشرة
على حوض الحمام ، فهي أول
شيء ألمسه وآمل أن أرتديه عندما
أستيقظ قبل أن تذهب إلى العمل
إذا كان بإمكانك
أن يقلل ذلك من فرصك  سأرغب فقط
في تخطيها في وقت لاحق من اليوم
لأنك متعب جدًا ، تعامل مع التدريبات الخاصة بك
بأهمية ، فهو لا يقل أهمية عن
الاجتماع مع أحد رؤسائك ، وقد
أحببت حقًا أن يبدأ هذا الجزء الأخير بشكل
يبعث على السخرية خمس دقائق
ثلاث مرات في الأسبوع  لا تستطيع أن تفعل ذلك ،
ثم تكثف مدتك
بالتردد ، وسرعان ما ستجد
طريقة لجعلها جزءًا من
روتينك المعتاد جسمك وعقلك جيدًا ،
شكرًا لك